do you know that when canvas came out
all the artists said that wasn't real
art that if you didn't put it on
buildings it wasn't real art you should
go read what they said about the
television like we always demonize new
technology humans are incredible at
romanticizing yesterday and demonizing
today
i love what you're saying about your dad
because we get so hung up on
that little [__]
that doesn't matter right that your
ponds what do you do
to block out that noise to make sure
that you're focusing on the things that
actually matter
you know for me it's a little weird
since i was like six years old i would
like roll up on grandparents at the
school yard when my friends grandparents
would come and would literally sit like
this and just ask them questions i just
was always into
wisdom old-school stuff this is such a
weird answer my answer if you're this is
this is super important because if you
lie to yourself you've already lost if
you're sitting here and uncomfortable
about this combo because you know you
are a yeller you're an underminer you're
political you've got a little poison in
you when you get when you get upset you
lose your cool you need to really take a
step back and like have this combo with
yourself because that's that's the thing
that's stopping you from doubling and
there's a way to win the reason i use my
dad i don't want to do that that's like
i don't want to razz dad
that's so extreme what he does because
he's off the chain on being frustrated
and crazy with his employees
so
i'll give you a wild answer
i think every person here
should go
and donate a day
at a retirement home
i'm being dead serious
i think
that i have a real hack for you
i think if you're struggling with
perspective and figuring out what the
[__] we're all doing here go to
retirement home
and donate your time and spend one day
you'll feel great there'll be some you
won't do many things that will make you
feel better and very quickly
on a saturday or a friday in six or
seven hours you will stop complaining
about dumb [__] you will also start
doing new [__] because you will become
petrified with the concept of regret
if you spend time in a retirement home
you will find out the word
regret will populate to your brain in a
way that it hasn't up until this point
you will realize all the things you're
scared about doing right now because
you're worried about somebody's opinion
about it you will start doing because
when you see regret in somebody's eyes
who's alive who can't do [__] about it
anymore it's tough
and so
for me it's just perspective i always
say things you know for me knock on wood
my life is more about the big wins for
me it's more about staying calm when the
great stuff is happening
for me it's always when the great stuff
is happening i always make pretend that
i lost a parent
it's my go-to
like today's a big day and we made lots
of money or got the big account or i'm
on the cover of magazine or i'm the guy
or this and that i'm assuming that you
still are human and that you you have
those moments where you feel yourself
trying to go into that i'm human in the
headspace i'm human but i am this is for
the people that
really know my content well who here
consumes a good amount of my content or
has contacts
[Applause]
so for for thank you so for those people
this might surprise you unless you're
really looking under the nuances i'm
completely detached from my professional
success
like utterly detached
so what drives you
the
a level of gratitude and guilt that i
have such a natural talent to
communicate and execute that i can have
a profound impact and i feel a sense of
obligation to kind of
leave it on the field it's not wasted
yeah it's kind of a curiosity of like
how good can i do it
you know
like it's like
what
you know again for the people that raise
their hands and for the people that
don't know me well like my big thesis is
you have to cut out the noise all of it
especially the positive noise
when everybody tells you you're great
and you're awesome you become addicted
to that now you're completely vulnerable
to the negativity the reason i'm so out
there on social is because it's hard to
be so out there and social
most people can't deal with the heat
they don't like when somebody says
they're ugly or stupid or full of [__]
or a scam artist or they suck or they're
overrated
people don't like that
i don't care not because i'm so cool
it's because that person doesn't know me
how can i possibly be upset when
sallypants47 is having a bad day
sallypants47 is having a bad day and
decides to take it out on me because i
look too happy i meant but i'm not mad
at hate i'm compassionate to hate
but at the same token
knock on wood for me 90 of my comments
are just little goat emojis
and that and that and that requires
and that requires even more tune out
because when you get high on your own
supply it's a wrap
so let's switch well i love that i'm
going to switch a little bit more to the
i think it's more like regular stuff
please
crypto yeah
yes what should we know
that you should put 100 hours of
homework into it because it will
completely engulf the rest of your life
let's start with that
so
now the people that were most excited
right now
i still think 99 percent of the shit's
going on right now is going to zero
so this is about the macro
this is internet 97.
this is really good if you're over 45
you should not be confused of what's
going on at all though most are you
already lived through the internet when
nobody understood how profound it was
going to be if you're over 45 that means
you lived all the way through high
school without the internet and then the
internet came and you watched the world
completely change if you're over 45 in
this room you remember when online
dating was the weirdest taboo [__] in
the world that's where all the papers
were
right and now and now it is the most
normalized thing
you know people people told me at nausea
when i launched winelibrary.com that
nobody would ever buy wine on the
internet i had real business people
millionaires telling me nobody will ever
buy wine on the internet my response as
a night a 20 year old kid was people
gonna buy everything on the internet
how did you know that because i
understand people and it was that
yeah i just had yeah which is why back
to not being high like what did i do
my parents had sex at the right second
i'm being serious like when you have a
when when your currency is such off the
charts intuition about what people are
going to do that they can't see it
themselves and you can
that's obviously as you can imagine a
very big money-making proposition if you
know everyone's going to be on social
media when in 2005 and again for the
crowd that's here like a lot of people
remember you're the majority of this
room in 2007 when they first heard about
twitter thought it was the stupidest
thing of all time i lived it i watched
it i had those 100 000 conversations who
cares if you're eating a pizza and my
brain would always say everyone
what is what are your thoughts on elon
taking over twitter
and not taking over it's gonna be really
it's gonna be really really really
interesting i think he's going to
operate you know or put an operator in
twitter has not evolved a whole lot from
its core product from 2007. i'm less
worried about like the freedom speech
thing this and that like i just think
humanity finds its way in the end you
have to be careful and thoughtful and
you know all that that's what's going to
get all the headlines who's going to
like is trump going to get reinstated
and that like all that stuff will take
the headlines i'm more curious of
is he going to build a subscription
product so that people can make a lot of
dollars for that is there going to be
more virality tick tock's dominating
because when you put out good content
you get unlimited virality twitter
doesn't have that per se at the same
scale so you know
long form video so i'm curious more
about just like a pure business sense of
like what's gonna happen there um so
that's where i'm at with that but i
think you know with crypto
you have to understand that the
blockchain is the biggest technology
change
and new invention since the internet the
reason most people are confused about
the blockchain is they bring their
internet rationale to the blockchain the
way that we all brought our normal life
rationale into the internet why would
anybody buy wine on the internet is what
everyone said the answer was because
it's convenient
right
the reason everybody in here is going to
interact with the blockchain is because
for many things in the world it's better
than the internet the joke about nft is
oh i can just right click and save
you're right on the internet you can't
own [__] that's not how it works on the
blockchain it's a ledger that's the
whole point of it
and so people are making headline
reading assumptions people talk you know
you know many people here have had
conversations about the blockchain nfts
and crypto
over dinner and have no idea what the
[__] they're actually talking about
i know this because i used to do it in
my 20s around healthcare or world events
or other [__] when i started actually
learning heavy about wine and then when
i felt confident about business and and
marketing i just stopped talking about
other [__] with that at least with the
level of like i know when i talk when i
get into a dinner table and they're
talking about health care i'm like if i
have an opinion i'm gonna hedge the [__]
out of it i'm like hey from somebody
that doesn't know [__] my thought is but
that's not how we talk now
we're at the most extreme version of
that now with social people out here
pontificating about [__] that they have
no idea about
that's like the cool thing to do which
is why everyone saw him [__] tilt
so let's fast forward back in the 90s
kids people that didn't know [__] kept
their mouth shut
so let's fast forward let's say five
maybe ten or whatever time frame you
want to give in gary's mind's eye paint
that picture of the world we're living
in
for
the blockchain how that how our lives
will look i think the thing that i so
the metaverse is still far away you know
people are all about the metaverse they
because it's exciting for people that
dream that way or it's scary as [__] for
people that are scared by it so it's a
hot topic but we don't have 10 million
people spending two hours a day in
goggles or in headsets yet so we're
still far away but the technology is
getting closer every day so it's looming
so i don't overly spend too much time on
the metaverse i've spent tens of
millions of dollars buying nfts i've
bought zero land in metaverse so my
actions back up my thought i think it
can happen i just think that you have to
be careful because when you don't get
timing right you lose and i spend a lot
of time on timing nfts on the other hand
i've been watching since 2017 when i saw
crypto kitties i'm like there's
something here i didn't fully understand
it i put on a shelf kind of kept my ear
nba top shot came out two years ago and
i was like wait a minute this is
starting to look like what i thought
back then i did some homework and i saw
that ethereum was really now starting to
get ready and that's why 2021 i went
hard because the timing was right and i
was right it was the time the reason i
like nfts is the same reason i like
nikes and burka and
all the clothes and bags and shoes that
everyone's wearing nfts
are a form of communication
the number one way that people
communicate in the world is through the
things they buy
there's a reason people buy rolex's
there's a reason that people buy bmws
there's a reason you buy a fancy trip
and then take 800 photos and put it all
over
there's a reason handbags can sell for
twenty thousand dollars it's called
communication nobody posts
their wealth by taking
a balance
photo
in their wells fargo and post it on
social media
but
but billions of people
share
indicators to their wealth or their
interests or their points of view on the
world
nothing does that more than what you buy
nothing is going to scale
nfts will scale greater than social
media pictures
on our
communication with each other which is
why it caught my attention which is why
i wanted to learn it so i'm spending a
ton of time trying to figure out nfts
the thing it has that's different than
fashion is it's a contract and a utility
in three weeks i'm gonna be in minnesota
at u.s bank stadium where the vikings
play football and they'll be 9 000
people there who all bought an nft for
me a year ago because that means they
have access to that conference because
the nft is also a ticket they're also
going to go to the next two
and so the utility on the back end every
ticket to every sporting event nft every
receipt to a high end item in 15 years
nft my plane ticket down here
uh by delta to puerto rico 10 years nft
because it's going to make sense the way
buying wine on the internet made sense
for delta if they want to have a
corporate initiative and maybe let's say
have an underprivileged artist from
ukraine design this month's plane
tickets
as instead of just a qr code it's now a
collectible piece of art it's not gonna
be the crazy wild wild west we have now
where everything's thousands of dollars
it might just be worth three bucks
but
that's all cards yeah that's right like
baseball cards or stamps or beanie
babies and beanie babies is a good comp
because that was an artificial market
built on overhype and that's what's
happening with individual nft projects
but when people like this is beanie
babies i'm like you're confused this is
stuffed animals
there are beanie babies within it yeah
got it this is a complete genre and so
the nft what's gonna happen is just like
internet stocks again i'm pointing to a
lot because i see the faces a lot of
over 40 year olds if you remember i know
we were kids at the time but
you know i was into business more than
let's say most teenagers but
all the internet stocks crashed hard in
2000 and all the articles in the wall
street journal and
you know the big magazines of the people
they all wrote articles see the internet
was a fad because they got confused they
they called the internet based on stock
price not based on the technology
no question in my mind in the next 24
months the majority of nft projects that
are worth a lot of money right now are
going to zero
because the supply and demand doesn't
make sense
and they'll be unlimited articles i'm
probably going to have to have a month
of defending myself even though i've
made a million [__] videos like this
and everyone's going to see nfps we're
stupid we told you and then that's when
the action's going to really start
because the technology is undeniable so
you think we might see this we're kind
of we're in this crescendo it's going to
fall and it'll kind of grind yeah
so to make this valuable for everybody
for your small business your big
business your consumer this isn't about
going out and buying nfts this is about
going out and buying an nft for fifty
dollars just to go through the
experience because you probably recall
yourself or your parents or your
grandparents not willing to do email in
not willing to get an iphone some of you
in here said you'd never give up your
blackberry because you needed those
[__] buttons
all of you have iphones
so right now a lot of you are like this
is stupid i don't get it
whatever you can't
you can't
it's gonna eat up the world over the
next decade
like unless you plan on wrapping it up
in the next 10 years you just can't so
the quicker you start getting educated
making yourself uncomfortable learning
making mistakes figuring it out
because once you start understanding it
then you might be able to use it for
offense because right now it's defense
as a thesis
[Applause]
i know i've heard you talk a lot about
well like you said from you know
searching it you know when you said i
was thinking of my mom because she was
in school and they said oh we're going
to email and she's like why the heck
would we use email i can just walk down
to the other classroom and just you know
give you know teacher so-and-so a
message i know i've heard you see
[__] do you know do you know i
apologize do you know that when canvas
came out all the artists said that
wasn't real art that if you didn't put
it on buildings it wasn't real art
you should go read what they said about
the television
like we always demonize new technology
humans are incredible at romanticizing
yesterday and demonizing today
so i get it good so i know you're
bullish on tick-tock
what do you what are you most bullish on
in terms of if someone had to pick one
form of communication marketing channel
etc this is why q a is so fun because
it's a game of self-awareness if for
example if you're incredibly insecure of
your visual exp appearance
you can't do video
it's a it's a mental block
right so now you might have to do audio
which all of a sudden becomes should you
do twitter and do audio posts and post
there right like
for example i am even though i'm a five
or six time new york times best-selling
author i can't put two sentences
together
i like i that's why i have to record all
my books everyone i love when people
come to my when i do books and i have
book settings man the book sounds just
like you and i'm always laughing i'm
like because i [__] recorded it
and somebody put it into sentence form
you know um
that you know so for me
i i'm not gonna go to linkedin and write
four paragraphs over you know while i
have a cigar or a glass of wine or or on
the tread like we're walking you know
but for me as many of you know video
comes very natural so i think first
you have to know yourself of what format
allows you to communicate for a lot of
people here being an independent little
a little scary maybe having a sidekick
or a friend now all of a sudden you got
a podcast
right so you have to know yourself first
after that to be very frank if you
actually know how they all work
they can all be great you can dominate
on twitter you can dominate on a you can
dominate maybe you're a great host or
hostess all of a sudden maybe it's a
facebook group that you should be
building right so there's a lot of ways
to win now there are always moments of
time where there's so much attention on
a platform that if you post you get more
organic reach without paying everybody
always gets mad at the algorithms that's
just supply and demand you weren't there
early enough
instagram [__] me it's free
i get like a billion dms from
influencers gary instagram [__] me i'm
like it was free you made millions it
was free
so
algorithms change not because you're a
conservative it's because they're
running a [__] business and more
content means less and less consumption
means supply and demand more more kids
went from instagram to tick-tock
more people are posting to instagram
than did two years ago what the thing
what do you think is gonna happen of
course your video is not gonna get a
hundred thousand views anymore it's
gonna get 40 000 it's called supply and
demand of attention
that's what i trade that has been the
foundation of my career i had email
newsletter in the 90s that had 95 open
rates i bought every wine term in the
world on google adwords the day google
adwords started i started a youtube show
long form was one of the first five
humans on earth to do it i was one of
the first 30 people to have a million
followers on twitter like this is my
career
and so i understand it and so the answer
is figure out your form of communication
if you're capable of doing tick tock you
go all in and tick tock is not you know
three years ago i'm like tick tock tick
tock tick tock and everyone's like it's
14 year old girls dancing i'm like for
now
facebook used to be just college kids
now it's just grandmas
it changes
[__] changes it evolves and so you're on
facebook quite a bit no worries me too
listen
i just got done saying it's my favorite
platform right now because like no
emotion complete detachment
the complete attachment
it's just whatever the market wants
and so many people make
judgments subjectively in their mind
about things
and it's a it's a mistake
what's up
hey sean uh this is actually a two-part
question for both of y'all same
questions
um gary vee i was not that familiar with
you until then
but um
how do you stay grounded
by this detaching yourself from the
success that you require over how much
yeah for me it's just like at the end of
the day who cares if i'm good at making
money
like really like really
because my mom
instilled really good human traits in me
and the concept of trying to make
somebody else feel insecure in my
presence because i'm just not insecure
that's why i'm a man
just not insecure
you know and if you're not insecure
then you have no interest in flexing
i think for me to stay grounded i i do
two things one is uh if i just have one
person that says thank you that was
awesome you help me whatever that like
i'll take as many arrows in my back
as as people will throw me if i know
that it's helping that one person that's
one thing and also too my baseline is
extremely low
and what i mean by that is i could i
could lose everything and i could have a
tent and i would be fine as long as i
had my health because
well
my mom my dad lived in the tent raising
her you know on a homestead so like i've
been there so my baseline is so low i
could lose everything and it yeah it
would suck but it doesn't matter it's
such an interesting point i've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
how much happens in the first five years
of your life
right just shit's getting formed in that
little brain
and it's funny what you just said my
obsession
lately is if you're lucky enough to be
born with little
little
no money
but have a happy home you're [__]
unbeatable
if you're taught early on that money
isn't happiness
you because if you're born with a lot of
money and there's happiness you're
subconsciously believing that's the
driver
right if you're if obviously if you're
born into no money and there's a lot of
unhappiness in the home you believe that
money will get you out of that but when
you're lucky enough to not have anything
and have happiness in the home you're
[__] moonwalking so you're like this
because we grew up with electricity half
the time
and i was getting my mom your mom was a
hippie as [__] huh yeah okay
so i gave my mom crap earlier because
you gotta think when first video games
came out they didn't have a save option
yeah it's devastating you're like in the
middle of things like you're
you're like you're like about to like
face you're like you're about to beat
zelda and the power goes down
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way if you're 45 and you played
mike tyson's punch out the first time
you saw mike tyson in that stage you
were like this is the crazy that was the
and then when he hit you and you got
knocked out if he hit you once that was
insane sorry just a little
nintendo nerd
so in terms of
in terms of entering the market so this
is kind of a two-part question
uh
people that are in the market today
what would you suggest people enter into
and how do you facilitate grit in our
kids
i
gritting your kids is by not giving them
[__]
i'll give you a very easy answer for
that one i'll spend two seconds on that
i have all these friends i live in
manhattan you can imagine and we're
gonna teach grit i'm like
you just
bought them everything
there's only one way to teach grit
it's by not giving gary i first want to
say thank you changed my life five years
ago self awareness curiosity thank you
you're welcome and my partner jared you
have a positioning publishing company
because we still believe in the
foundation of identity from books okay a
lot of people said close to finish right
we tell us what you've learned from
books nfps communities and building
culture
as you guys probably know like i was so
out in front of all the new tech stuff
back in the day and then i kept writing
books and i would get such you know the
first book came out i got so pounded
like what the [__] like you know social
media the future technology why are you
writing a book and i was like because
people read them
you know to me i always laugh when
people are like this is dead i'm like
okay it could be but like right now
currently it might be declining slowly
everybody thinks everything's going to
happen so fast you know like i built an
entire marketing
big company we almost have 2 000 people
now vayner's a monster on the thesis
that network television commercials were
garbage it's just now happening
right because of streaming
right and so
you know what i've learned is that
when you are doing things for them and
not yourself
you'll make much better decisions and
whether it's books or nfts or
photography or anything else
for every person here similar to the way
i want you to think about your employees
if you think about your customers from
the standpoint of why is it good for
them versus what i see for most people
which is why is this good for me
you'll just get a lot more for you i
think that's the thing i really admire
about you gary is that you
rather than fight the way things are
you're able to see that and be able to
see around corners and you're able to
anticipate what's coming next and just
put yourself there it's like you're
skating i'm i'm also in a very
yeah
you know
this is very important you have to ask
yourself what your relationship is with
money
it's imperative
so much of my luck
is because i don't like it enough
all my friends are like
you know
all my friends have like i have so many
friends that have moved to puerto rico
in miami and texas it's like [__] out
of control right and they love to like
razz me they're like you're in [__]
you know like you're not only are you in
new york you're in new york city you're
paying city tax like they'll go on a
whole 13 [__] and i make real money
that's real money and and they'll like
go on a 13-minute [__] rant and then
i'm like
i don't care
[Music]
and they're just like baffled
i'm like i like new york i i need the
action i don't want to [__] live in
l.a in l.a or miami or puerto rico or
[__] ecuador i want to live in
[__] manhattan
and so like but for other people they
love money and guess what
zero judgment
who the [__] am i [__] me i don't care
if
if if they wanna if they wanna move from
la to [__] austin texas knock
yourself out if you wanna move from
[__] connecticut to [__] the
outskirts of miami have a [__] ball
the thing that i love is my mom has no
idea who gary is
my favorite thing is that my favorite
thing is that seven billion people have
no idea who the [__] i am this is what
drives me crazy somebody gets like eight
followers on tick tock they're like
what's the [__] matter with you
i'm really glad that you're the lollipop
guy on tick tock now sit the [__] down
and calm down
i don't understand people
that's my man
high schoolers
is that predicated on you trying to
maximize your financial impact like i
would go into something that wouldn't
bore me
you know what i mean like the questions
framed in a way of like there's a really
fun question i get from you characters
which is like the people i love the most
like the youngsters
to me that's a really tough question
because it's always framed in the way
you just did it which is
binaurally based on where is their
financial opportunity
meanwhile i'm 46 now and for the last 20
years i've been nothing but around
people who do real estate and wall
street in manhattan and want to jump out
[__] windows because they hate it so
much and they're [__] they literally
the only reason they do it is to make
697 000 a year to buy cars and clothes
to cover up their pain so i have no
interest in telling you to do that you
should be like his mom and go to oregon
and not have electricity if that makes
you happy
[Applause]
you know what i mean like like right now
it makes sense especially if you're here
you're like i'm gonna listen i was on f
do you know what i was thinking when i
was exactly your age at this point i'm
like i'm gonna buy the jets i'm gonna be
the best businessman of all time but
that was in me
that was in me i was a dnf student i'm
46 in the 80s and 90s all this [__] was
not cool it was go to harvard or you
suck
right and so for me i was fighting the
system back then my fear is now the
reverse you might want to be a [__]
professor i don't know like to me
there's plenty of things that have money
in it do you like it do you want to sell
a [__] house
i mean right away like as soon as i hear
that i'm like definitely don't do real
estate
right
right like and by the way by the way
all all of our vibes right now is envy
do you know many people are sitting here
that hate what they do
i would give up everything to be you
because time is the only interesting
asset
so
you know i think
i think
you too are so lucky that you live in a
world where there's alternative
information
we
if we're older here
grew up there was one track
when i hear drumming like if you love
music you need to spend the next 15
years trying to make it in music before
you go and become practical how old are
you
right
so for the next 16 years of your life
from the second you came to this [__]
earth to right this second has been 16
years
if you tried to do something in music
for the next 16 years
next 16 years
you'd be 32 when that journey was over
which is still ridiculously young enough
to get a practical job in real estate
that
we're going to do we'll do a rapid fire
here
so you can keep as long as you're short
as you can we'll get through as many as
we can
who's putting out healthy messages and
not just physical health but just
messages that you resonate you like that
you that you follow and enjoy i don't
follow anybody
um
because i follow everybody that's true i
don't you know
i don't say that like i'm cool i say it
because i spend almost all of my time
when i consume anything trying to
understand what everybody is consuming
so you're watching it from a from a from
a different place from perspective
you're not actually my consumption my
consumption and content is new york jets
football
from a visual standpoint the occasional
documentary
um
and then predominantly
reading my dms
looking at what's trending
going into forums and social to
understand what people are paying
attention to favorite movie
robin hood prince of thieves
i like that i like that movie um
favorite movie for me is probably star
wars i think star i think star wars
is one of the most interesting
pieces of content ever made because i
think it goes to the crux of something
that we're dealing with actually right
now i would argue that star wars has
helped me through the last seven or
eight years of political tension in our
society because
star wars basic principle is that
humans or good is just slightly better
than humans bad
that that jedis are just
enough better than the dark side and so
i've always loved the real like
simplicity of the macro message of that
film plus i saw it when we first came to
america
like it was like it was just a very
emotional like american thing for me
when i first got here what habits do you
need to change about yourself that you
want to change
it's funny i tend not to be vulnerable
in my content because i'm like people
got their own [__] to worry about um but
don't worry about it i i in my last book
i went into it 12 and a half um i
want to be more candace
which blows people's mind because as a
public figure
yeah in this format i'm candace as [__]
in real life i'm incredibly
non-confrontational and i hate hurting
people's feelings and um and so and i
just started being a jerk
no no i actually i actually really broke
it down heavy i
created this concept called kind candor
in my own mind and it completely changed
the way i've operated as a human being
i'm still on my journey but i am
light years ahead of where i was four
years ago and i want to continue because
it's really been obvious that when i
look back at my life everything that has
not gone well for me with employees
relationships like the things i care
about has been 100
predicated on my inability to be
cancerous when the other person wasn't
doing their thing and then eventually i
so misplayed it that it became my issue
instead of what it started as and it's
really changed
me and i'm really want to continue to
double down on it
how should people hedge inflation and
all everything that's going on
by saving money
i'm very surprised by how many people
are not willing to have an actual nest
egg
like even though i'm all in on crypto
and all this other stuff there'll never
be a day of my life where i don't have a
million dollars in cash buried somewhere
ever it will never happen
yeah and that's the that's the culture i
grew up in like i make a joke like in
russia because nobody was actually
allowed to have money when they had
money because everything was black
market they would actually bury it in
the backyard and so like like even when
i was like 15 i like i think my parents
have cash in the ground outside and so
um i really think for a lot of you i
know people want to invest they want to
be thoughtful with your money but like
it's just a good idea to have something
like and the way i play it is
i need to have something that if
everything goes to zero i can do
something with that
something over my head start my next gig
whatever that is so that's why that
number's gotten bigger over time it was
a hundred thousand dollars for a million
years because i'm also tent life um but
now i'm kind of like well i'll still
want to play and i'll i if everything
goes to [__] like that then a million
bucks is probably profound money at that
point and so
um i think everybody should have savings
i think it's a good idea
who would be someone that
that you that you have interviewed or
talked to yet that you'd love to talk to
what would you ask them
i don't really have those kind of
feelings either
i don't
that's not my framework i would tell you
that you know i find it interesting
i think everyone's interesting i mean
that like like i'm far more interested
with your mom's [__] oregon stuff
than let's say like
bill gates that's much more interesting
to me i'm very interested
in people which is so much of my
foundation
so i don't have like aspirations to like
sit down and talk to somebody i have
aspirations to take advantage of when i
stumble upon somebody at the airport or
on a train when i have time or spending
time with my team getting to know them
better um
i do you know i lost both of my
grandfathers before i got to know them i
have a lot of
interest in you know hoping you know i
have some real hopes and dreams
i actually have no expectations of
anybody or anything which is why i'm
always happy but i have real
expectations about heaven
i've got some big hopes and dreams for
heaven there's two core things i'm
really hoping about heaven one
that everyone's there and i can have
some real some real talks i got a lot of
questions from the people that are not
around anymore
and two which is really cool i think you
like this
i think that heaven
has
some weird version of google
where this is like i dream about this
where you go up there and you can type
in anything and heaven will show you
what would have happened for example
first thing i'm doing when i get to
heaven first first query
heaven
show me
the time i came closest to dying without
knowing it enter
and i have these two core scenarios one
if i would have eaten that peanut i
would have choked on it and died or two
my favorite one the time i forgot my
keys in the house ran out forgot ran
back in and grabbed them but had i
grabbed them i would have got hit by a
bus and died so i've got big hopes for
heaven
i'm going to be super pissed if it's not
there
and so uh i'm excited about that
question if someone that you see people
that they buy the shoes the watches the
starbucks but they're not willing to
invest in themselves and they say think
oh my gosh poor what was me how do you
get people to shift from the consumption
to investing in themselves i have so
many friends that like nice things they
always get mad at me because i put out a
lot of content about this and i don't do
a good enough job so i'm gonna try to be
better about it
the reason i talk about buying things is
because
if you really know if like you grew up
for 25 years 40 years like reading car
books and going to it and it was your
grandfather saying look like it makes
all the sense in the world when you get
to financial means that you want a
lamborghini what i'm worried about no
different than buying an nft or anything
else are the people who are buying it to
disguise the actual truth
they're using it as a proxy for their
insecurity it's how i'm going to get the
girl because i'm insecure it's how i'm
people going to think i'm successful
because they don't it's all that stuff i
get worried about that because i know
that's not a sustainable model for
happiness and i talk about that
you know
investing in yourself comes in a lot of
forms
you know it it's one thing to say don't
buy a starbucks for eight bucks or don't
buy a lamborghini or rolex and put it
into
a content a mastermind like things to
better yourself
my personal belief is better yourself is
a simple game of this
i actually think
most people need to downsize and
simplify at scale
maybe not as crazy as what your parents
did but
but that was an extreme version that
actually has a ton of merit well they
left l.a yeah
it it it
it was think about the time we were in
in america that led to a lot of that
kind of behavior and i actually think
there's a lot of truth in it like it's
so funny because i because i'm so into
business i'm into all this other stuff
that i love so it's not obvious what's
actually happening in my wiring but i
just want more simplicity for people
the more simplicity you have and and for
me simplicity comes in the form of
judgment
the thing that i'm trying to think as
much about as possible is how do i
have a conversation that might impact
someone positively about the concept of
judgment and it actually starts with
yourself
the thing that i'm really hot on right
now is of course so many people are
judging each other they start with
themselves
i just wish people wouldn't beat
themselves up so much like i hate when
people are like oh but gary you don't
get it on me i'm just i'm so ambitious
i'm like i'm the [__] craziest
ambitious person i've ever met my life
that doesn't mean that if i don't win
this year or this decade that i think
i'm a piece of [__] that's not healthy
and i definitely don't have envy envy is
a framework of conversation that has to
be eliminated how can you envy someone
when you don't know them
you know a piece of them
you know a headline of them you might
like something that's going on with them
how can you actually envy somebody that
you know nothing about we just have to
simplify
but
like for me it's so simple to be content
and hungry as [__] at the same time
i've come to know that that's confusing
and sounds like a contradiction but i
have to continue to unpack it because in
that is [__] everything it's the
whole game when you like want it more
like i want to be the greatest human
that ever lived
i genuinely swear on my children's
health as i sit in front of you here
right now that when i die in 55 years
when i'm in heaven doing my google [__]
i'm going to look down and i'm like
okay good seven billion people came to
my funeral that's how i wake up every
day trying to navigate my life
at the same token
if it all ended tomorrow and nine people
came that's fine too and finding that
balance of extremities to make it
balance not like something that's
confusing is something we have to talk
more about and so to answer your
question in a very long-winded way
what i would say to that person is break
it down get simpler
tune out the noise
most of all tune out your own noise
against yourself
everybody else is going to have judgment
on you you need to be your number one
[__] fan for real not kidding and i
will remind you
no matter who the [__] you look up to
they suck at a lot of things too
thank you let's give it up
[Music]
you